I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance when I was a kid my dad used
to tell me of a dream he had again and
again starting in the late 50s he was at
his draftsman desk looking at his office
window in Union Square in New York City
watching a perfect spring day trotting
towards its sunset hearing the sounds of
life and humanity through the open
window and perceiving with his artist's
eye the balance of the contrasting
colors in the vivid sky and the city
more vivid still beneath and then
noticing out at the horizon over the
water the mushroom cloud it was a
nightmare but it was one rooted
horrifically in a reality of nuclear
annihilation a nightmare that got just a
little bit worse every day
and which as he noted you then had to
pretend wasn't reality and you had to
pretend wasn't getting worse every day
and you had to pretend wasn't abnormal
and you had to pretend wasn't inhuman
and you had to pretend it wasn't
unacceptable until you ended the day
exhausted by the sheer amount of your
life spent pretending that it was just
fine better to find ways small ones
symbolic ones impossible financial ones
to fight back you are spending just as
much energy he said I was too young to
share his nightmare and he has gone too
many years to share mine but wise words
stand the test of time and his words
were wise at the [ __ ] grabber in
Chief's victory party a woman named
Omarosa Manigault who was briefly on
television said of people who did not
vote for him quote I would never judge
anybody for exercising their right to
and the freedom to choose who they want
but let me just tell you mr. Trump has a
long memory and we're keeping a list we
have to pretend that isn't abnormal then
the chief of the campaign is named the
chief strategist in the White House and
he has a track record of mile long of
antipathy to women and black people and
all of a sudden you realize MS Manigault
who is both is herself pretending that
he isn't abnormal and she isn't a target
and then we get half a dozen different
answers about whether or not the victor
in the presidential election who lost
the popular vote is going to shatter all
precedent by fulfilling his campaign
boast and become
personally involved in the prosecution
of the loser in that election and all of
a sudden the media is pretending that
this isn't abnormal and last Sunday the
president-elect who lost the popular
vote finally speaks about the Clintons
and says I don't want to hurt them I
don't want to hurt them they're they're
good people as if the decision whether
or not to prosecute somebody in this
country is to be decided about how the
president personally feels about them
and now we all have to pretend that this
isn't abnormal then the outgoing
minority leader of the Senate Harry lead
actually doesn't pretend and he says the
election quote has emboldened the forces
of hate and bigotry in America and is
being celebrated by white nationalists
Putin and Isis quote while innocent
law-abiding Americans are racked with
fear to which the campaign manager of
the banana Republicans Kellyanne Conway
replies he should be very careful about
characterizing somebody in a legal sense
he thinks he's just being some kind of
political pundit here but I would say be
very careful about the way you
characterize it and then miss Conway
pretends she wasn't referring to a
lawsuit even though she used the phrase
legal sense which I guess necessarily
means she was thus referring not to a
lawsuit but to a prosecution and once
again we must pretend this isn't
abnormal and the CNN Headline after it
actually reads Conway Reid trade barbs
over Trump as if criticism and threats
against the First Amendment are somehow
equivalent and the pretending escalates
and it is reported that the transition
team allegedly asked the White House how
the children of this man could receive
top-secret security clearance the
children who are supposed to be running
the anything but blind business trust
that we have to pretend is a real blind
business trust a trust for the man who
have to pretend did not spend the
campaign accusing his opponent of
mishandling classified information and
then the radio conspiracy peddler Alex
Jones announces Trump has phoned to
thank him and to promise to be on his
show soon and now we have to pretend
Alex Jones hasn't claimed that the
massacre at Sandy Hook was staged and we
have to pretend that he isn't crazy and
we have to pretend that it's not
abnormal for a man elected
president the United States to even
acknowledge that an Alex Jones exists
let alone to feed his machine of madness
and brutality and then the cabinet names
start falling and we have to pretend
Giuliani isn't an international
political [ __ ] who hasn't taken money
from repressive elements everywhere from
Qatar to El Salvador
and who's now consulting uber but of
course they all have to pretend as well
they have to pretend that there aren't
still avenues open to us for economic
blowback
Giuliani uber stop using uber Alex Jones
that creature is on a hundred radio
stations google them call them up
identify their advertisers boycott their
advertisers the ludicrous media
equivalencies and the euphemisms that
normal eyes hate and enable pretending
don't tweet don't call the writer don't
call the editor call the president of
news or his boss at his corporation I
promise you from personal experience
they always overreact trump's hidden tax
returns and the first for-profit
presidency
how many Trump businesses can you avoid
how many firms that applauded his
election like New Balance can you make
go bankrupt just this week the owners
and residents of three New York
apartment buildings got the names of
their places changed they are now 140
Riverside Drive 160 Riverside Drive and
180 Riverside Drive
they were Trump Place these are the
kinds of protests against pretending
that we can make and the kind that will
hit the ego elect the hardest that and
forever referring to the fact that he
lost the popular vote and then we gear
up for the biggest fight against
pretending of our lives
that man elected by a minority of voters
says he will immediately incarcerate or
deport 2 to 3 million undocumented
Americans which is roughly the same
number of people who live in Houston
Texas which is roughly the same number
of people who are already in all of the
federal prisons and all the state
prisons and all the county jails and all
the city jails and all the ice detention
facilities and all the Navy Briggs and
all the army stockades and all the
military disciplinary barracks all of
them combined which leaves no inference
possible except that he somehow
means to take two to three million
people off our streets and keep them
somewhere until they can be jailed or
deported and that we again have to
pretend that this somewhere for a
population roughly the same size as all
the prisoners in all the jails in this
country right now we have to pretend
that this will not involve concentration
camps but to worry he's unifying the
nation
Kellyanne Conway said so go back to
pretending this isn't getting worse
every day
this isn't abnormal this isn't inhuman
this isn't unacceptable resist peace